yeah do you want to say hi
say hi hi true thompson is
ready for her close-up okay khloe
kardashian's two-year-old daughter who
she shares with tristan thompson
did what kids do best in quaran times
she interrupted her mama
trying to do some work isn't that crazy
i am so
proud and happy for the push team and my
sister courtney
i know how hard it is to start any
business let alone
an econ business and in times of this
pandemic and this crazy world but court
i'm so proud of you
well okay she wasn't exactly doing work
work but she was shooting a little promo
congrats video for her older sister
kourtney kardashian's push website
courtney just launched an online store
shop.pooch.com
where you can buy all of her fabulous
things that she loves and raves about
go and check it out and me
yeah yeah that's when true chimed in
do you want to say hi say hi hi
coco shared the cute exchange on her
insta story monday but the sweet little
interruptions didn't stop there
hi everyone i am so excited because i
yes can i help you okay
you brought me eggs thank you goose
true i'm filming something for auntie
court
i'm filming mommy behind you behind me
oh no your eggs right there oh your egg
and the knife and stuff
well um i just got this amazing i gotta
make me a big what
you gave me a white egg thank you
um i got i love pusha's mailers she
captioned the clip quote i
lost my train of thought i failed we had
fun
but this isn't the first time a
kardashian kiddo has crashed their mom's
video
hi everyone in california it's kim
kardashian west and i just wanted to
talk to you and northwest back in april
north
straight up inserted herself in kim
kardashian's stay-at-home psa
i know that can you not jump on the bed
give me like two seconds to seriously do
this
and the seven-year-old wouldn't leave
her mom alone while she filmed
a makeup tutorial i'm hiding in the
guest room you guys i'm hiding in the
guest room because my kids
will not leave me alone hey that's me
hiding from your kids in the bathroom is
a real mood
north can i please just do my little
tutorial i i
it's all i want to do is one little fun
thing for myself
but back to cute little true i know
on wednesday chloe hit up instagram to
show how she and her little girl are
giving back this holiday season
you look so pretty in your christmas
outfit
the mommy daughter duo stopped by the
local fire station to donate to a toy
drive
and the whole thing is exactly the kind
of holiday cheer
we need in 2020
the 36 year old reality star captioned
the sweet post in part
quote i know true is young but i think
it is important for her to understand
how blessed
and fortunate she is it's so important
for her to see how we give back to
others
especially in such unprecedented times
and she wrapped
the whole thing up in a pretty bow
writing happy holidays from true and i